[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous je vais vous emmener tout
de suite on va partir ensemble vous
allez m'accompagner et on part dans la
jungle
je vous laisse un petit peu imaginer on
va faire travailler votre imagination
tout de suite la jungle amazonienne
végétation hyper dense
il fait chaud il fait humide donc on est
assez moite on est en mode survie on n'a
pas beaucoup de nourriture pas beaucoup
d'eau on galère un petit peu j'ai la
machette donc je vais pouvoir légionner
c'est à dire couper les végétaux pour
avancer la progression elle est quand
même assez pénible et
parfois on va mettre une heure pour
avancer de seulement 200 mètres
au bout de deux jours ça fait deux jours
on commence à avoir quand même bien soif
bien fin et bien en galère la végétation
s'ouvre un petit peu ça s'éclaircit
plutôt positif
là vous sentez une odeur que vous ne
connaissez pas forcément mais par contre
votre cerveau il analyse tout de suite
cette odeur comme étant un signal
d'alerte un danger
et là je vous pose une question
que feriez-vous face à un jaguar qui de
toute évidence vous charge
je vous avoue que cette question là il y
a 15 20 ans j'aurais jamais pensé avoir
à me la poser et pourtant en un quart de
seconde il y a toute une conversation
qui se fait dans ma tête une grosse part
de résignation c'est l'heure c'est
l'heure pour tout mon agent et moi c'est
la
et en même temps j'ai vécu des belles
aventures j'ai eu une vie déjà bien
remplie j'ai bien profité et puis un
petit sursaut d'optimisme
voilà
je reviendrai tout à l'heure sur cette
histoire de Jaguar et je vous raconterai
le fin mot de l'histoire mais avant je
voudrais vous raconter comment ces
expériences de survie un petit peu
extrême mon permis de tirer des leçons
et je vais aborder quatre notions clés
qui aujourd'hui me permettent de me
sortir de quasiment toutes les
situations et de toutes les difficultés
si ces quatre notions clés elles peuvent
m'aider moi dans ma vie quotidienne
elles vont pouvoir vous aider vous aussi
à surmonter tous les défis qui peuvent
vous sembler insurmontable
vous avez compris j'ai un métier un
petit peu atypique
et en fait je suis formatrice en survie
la première des leçons c'est celle-ci
donc je vais encore vous emmener avec
moi par ailleurs cette fois-ci on part
au bout de Swana il fait encore très
chaud mais beaucoup plus sec et ça fait
24 heures que j'ai pas trouvé d'eau
24 heures sans boire au bout de sauna
mon verre il est franchement vide
donc là j'ai deux options petit 1 je
peux me mettre en PLS et attendre que ça
se passe
là c'était dans le cadre d'un tournage
télé donc on aurait fini par venir me
secourir un moment ou un autre ça aurait
été un peu pénible mais on se rallume
chercher et la deuxième option c'est
celle que j'ai fait c'est d'essayer de
voir le verre à moitié plein essayer de
lister ce qui me restait alors de l'eau
visiblement pas beaucoup mais qu'est-ce
que je peux avoir pour me permettre de
trouver de l'eau
un petit peu de matériel
une petite liste de ce que j'ai mis deux
bras mais deux jambes quelques points de
cuit plus beaucoup mais quelques-uns et
puis l'environnement autour de moi grâce
à cette petite check lisse mentale j'ai
pu trouver plusieurs sources d'eau 20 ml
de sérum physiologique dans mes dans ma
trousse de secours dans mes pipettes de
trousse de secours
c'est pas grand chose mais quand on a
rien c'est un petit début
les végétaux autour de moi je les ai mis
dans un sac étanche et je les ai fait
transpirer là encore c'est pas fameux en
terme de rendement mais pas grand chose
plus pas grand chose bah ça commence à
faire quelque chose
ensuite
mon urine
là encore c'est une expérience que je ne
comprends pas mais ça reste une
expérience et malgré tout ça m'a permis
de tenir quelques heures de plus
et puis le dernier chose c'est prendre
de la hauteur donc en fait c'est
littéralement j'ai trouvé une petite
colline je suis allée en haut de la
colline j'ai pu avoir une vue un peu
plus dégagée sur la région environnante
et j'ai pu trouver comme ça un petit
point d'eau il y avait pas grand chose
mais il y avait un petit point d'eau
voir le verre à moitié plein la positive
attitude c'est vraiment ça c'est pas
être Béa et heureux quand tout
s'effondre autour de vous mais c'est
plutôt arrivé à identifier ce qui vous
reste et à vous focaliser sur ce que
vous avez aussi mince ça puisse vous
sembler plutôt que de vous focaliser sur
ce que vous avez perdu ou ce que vous
n'avez plus
la positive attitude
je vais encore vous demander de me
suivre un petit peu dans mon délire de
survie mais en fait vous allez tout de
suite comprendre que le point suivant si
ça marche en situation extrême en
réalité ça marche pour tout
il y a un auteur assez connu qui
s'appelle John ways Man qui a fait cette
pyramide c'est ce qu'on appelle la
pyramide de la survie en fait c'est
quels sont les moyens qui sont
importants
pour survivre quand on est en
environnement hostile ou en
environnement un peu engagé la base de
la survie c'est la volonté la volonté
l'attitude le mindset vous appelez ça
comme vous voulez la niaque ensuite
viennent les connaissances les
compétences
les capacités physiques seulement après
ça aide mais c'est pas primordial et en
tout dernier le matériel
cette pyramide de Wiseman je crois que
j'en suis l'illustration vivante le
matériel j'en utilise un petit peu mais
j'aime bien prouver qu'on peut faire ça
les capacités physiques
par un athlète de haut niveau je pense
que ça se voit et pourtant j'ai fait des
trucs de dingue
les connaissances les compétences
là on commence à tenir un peu un truc à
tenir un peu un truc et la volonté
clairement c'est mon point fort la
volonté la niaque ça tout le monde là
cette volonté plus ou moins ça se
travaille mais tout le monde a cette
volonté donc cette leçon là c'est la
volonté c'est la base de la survie
parfois on a la positive attitude
parfois on a une volonté qu'on a un
petit peu musclé mais on a quand même
pas beaucoup de ressources
on a très très peu de choses
ça tombe bien parce qu'il y a quelqu'un
qui s'appelle Pareto je pense que vous
connaissez tous qu'à éviter cette petite
règle aussi la loi de Pareto qui dit que
20 % des efforts produisent 80% des
effets
20% de votre matériel va vous apporter
80% de votre confort 20% du matériel
vous apportera 80% de sécurité 20% de
compétences 80% de résultats
et la base de la survie c'est quoi parce
que dans ces 20% qu'est-ce qui est le
plus important la base de la survie vous
vous souvenez
la volonté
la volonté le mindset du coup votre
volonté c'est vos 20% des forts qui vont
vous offrir les 80% de résultats
il y a plein de méthodes pour travailler
votre mindset pour développer votre
niaque il y en a une qui marche très
très bien c'est ce que j'appelle la
formulation positive
le cerveau humain ne connaît pas la
négation je vais prendre l'exemple
parlant si je vous dis ne pensez pas un
jaguar rose vous l'avez tous vu
il faut arriver à formuler les choses
positivement parce que le cerveau ne va
se focaliser que sur les mots moi quand
je suis parti dans la jungle mon
histoire de Jaguar du début
j'ai été un petit peu briefée la veille
de mon départ et puis on m'avait bien
dit si jamais tu rencontres un jaguar ça
n'arrive jamais mais si tu rencontres un
ne tourne pas le dos et ne cours pas
ne tourne pas le dos ne court pas tourne
court voilà ce que mon savoir retenu
voilà ce qui s'est passé
j'ai tourné le dos et je suis parti en
courant
histoire
si on m'avait dit reste calme et montre
au Jaguar que tu n'es pas une menace
peut-être que j'aurais agi autrement
l'histoire le dit pas mais peut-être que
ça aurait été différent
du coup ça c'est le point là c'est 20%
d'efforts économiser vos ressources
économiser vos points de cuit économiser
votre mental
et la formulation positive c'est une des
méthodes qui va vraiment vous aider
maintenant vous avez votre verre à
moitié plein vous avez votre positive
attitude
vous avez développé votre volonté vous
avez
identifié les quelques ressources qui
vous restaient qui étaient importantes
par quoi on commence
on est toujours face à notre difficulté
on commence par quel morceau
et ben c'est l'étape suivante c'est
prioriser en survie c'est facile de
prioriser parce que là encore on a un
petit moyen de mimotechnique
c'est redoutes qu'il a édité que ça
s'appelle la règle des trois
de quoi ai-je besoin pour rester en vie
plus de 3 minutes
j'ai besoin d'air donc c'est le fait de
respirer mais c'est aussi tout ce qui
est premier secours parce qu'en fait le
sang achemine l'oxygène enfin voilà
trois minutes sans air
3 heures sans abri et son chaleur peut
mourir d'une hypothermie en trois heures
on peut mourir d'une attaque de Jaguar
en moins de trois heures donc s'abriter
des prédateurs s'abriter des conditions
météo s'abriter du froid se protéger du
froid et se réchauffer
trois jours sans boire trois semaines
sans manger
on peut rajouter 3 mois sans hygiène et
sans contact sociaux et trois secondes
sont vigilance
ça c'est facile on survie on a ce petit
moyen mnémotechnique mais vous dans
votre vie quotidienne vous êtes face à
votre difficulté vous êtes face à votre
challenge comment est-ce que vous allez
faire et ben vous allez le découper par
petits morceaux et vous allez prioriser
ces morceaux le plus vital en premier et
puis les autres derrière une fois que
vous aurez attaqué le premier morceau et
que vous aurez résolu ce premier
problème tout va vous sembler tellement
facile derrière et tout va dérouler
finalement tout seul et va être fluide
apprendre à prioriser
vous aurez compris j'ai une expérience
du coup qui est un peu particulière et
franchement atypique et finalement cette
expérience de vie un petit peu extrême
enfin franchement extrême
et ben elle s'applique complètement dans
votre vie quotidienne
pour l'histoire du jaguar
ce qui s'est passé donc le jaguar a
chargé j'ai fait une sorte de
dissociation
mon cerveau était en train de voir ce
Jaguar qui me croquer la jugulaire
mon corps lui de son côté était en train
de courir
aussi vite que je pouvais et puis j'ai
eu un espèce de sursaut d'optimisme et
je me suis dit que peut-être je pouvais
mourir dignement j'avais une machette
dans la main qui avait peut-être un coup
à jouer
j'ai fait demi-tour
et je me suis retrouvé face au Jaguar
qui en fait c'était déjà stoppé il
voulait juste c'était juste une manœuvre
d'intimidation ça a très très bien
marché il va très bien intimidé il y a
pas de souci
et donc j'ai reculé pas très sereinement
et je suis partie rejoindre mon binôme
qui était déjà bien bien loin lui avec
ma machette et comme à chaque fois que
je suis soumise à un stress immense
j'ai été prise une crise de fou rire et
puis d'un moment d'euphorie totale et
absolue
les quatre notions clés que vous devrez
retenir
la positive attitude
pas simplement le fait d'être heureux et
joyeux quand tout va mal mais vraiment
identifier ce qui vous reste
identifié les ressources qui vous
restent la volonté qui est la base de
tout l'envie de réussir
économisez vos ressources et surtout
votre mental vos points de cuit
avec entre autres la formulation
positive il y a plein d'autres
techniques qui peuvent vous y aider
la priorisation découpée votre votre
problème en petits morceaux et commencer
par le plus vital pour ensuite vous
attaquer au reste juste ces quatre
petits messages ces quatre petites
notions face à n'importe quelle
difficulté n'importe quel changement
majeure de votre vie ça va vous
permettre de prendre du recul et ça va
vous permettre de dédramatiser la
situation
en fait vous allez vous rendre compte
que grâce à ça en fait toutes les
ressources dont vous avez besoin pour
arriver à bout de votre problème
toutes les ressources en fait elles sont
immédiatement disponibles parce qu'en
fait vous allez vous rendre compte que
depuis le début et en fait depuis
toujours les ressources elles sont en
vous
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]